The Harry Potter books and films have been
combed through by everyone who wished they'd
gotten a Hogwart's acceptance letter on their
11th birthdays.
But there are some details in the movies that
only die-hard Potter fans could really pluck
out.
Here are some Harry Potter Easter eggs that
only bona fide members of Dumbledore's Army
would've caught.
Snape's coded message
It took a long time for Harry Potter to figure
out that Professor Snape wasn't actually out
to get him and make his stay at Hogwarts miserable.
If he was a star student of language like
his pal Hermione, though, he might've been
able to unlock the Half-Blood Prince's true
intentions long before he got a screening
of Snape's memories through Dumbledore's Pensieve
in the final chapter.
In the Sorcerer's Stone, Snape challenges
Harry:
"Tell me, what would I get if I added powdered
root of asphodel to an infusion of wormwood?"
The moment seems like a check on Harry's sudden
star status as the big man on campus, but
in retrospect, superfans have always found
a little more weight to those words.
See, asphodel is actually a member of the
lily family and can invoke the phrase "my
regrets follow you to your grave".
Meanwhile, wormwood is literally defined as
something "bitter or grievous."
This has led many to believe that Snape was
really just telling Mister Potter that he
was bitterly regretful of his mother, Lily,
passing away.
Given the fact that he loved her most of his
life and clutched her corpse in agony the
day he discovered The Boy Who Lived, that
makes a lot of sense, then, doesn't it?
So much seven
Harry Potter's number on the Gryffindor Quidditch
Team is seven, and it's no accident: he's
the seventh of Voldemort's horcruxes, after
all, and there are seven books in the series.
So the filmmakers went to painstaking efforts
to include the fabled numerology throughout
the series, whether you noticed it or not.
There are a ton of things that just so happened
to add up to seven throughout the movies,
like the headcount on snakes that line the
door to the Chamber of Secrets, the number
of players on each Quidditch team, the number
of children in the Weasley family, and the
number of Harry Potters that are made from
the Order of the Phoenix to disguise the real
deal.
Looks like seven really was Harry's lucky
number...
Deathly Hallows everywhere
Speaking of visual iconography, the movies
also made a point of flashing the sign of
the Deathly Hallows during pivotal scenes
as well.
For example, in the Goblet of Fire, Dumbledore
gazes upon his collection of artifacts in
his office, and they're arranged in such a
way as to give us a wink to the triangle-circle-line
symbol that would represent the Cloak of Invisibility,
the Resurrection Stone, and the Elder Wand
later on in the story.
Another example comes in Deathly Hallows:
Part 2, when Harry, feeling bad about Dobby's
death, looks in the shard of mirror the house
elf had in his possession.
The lens of his glasses and a streak of glare
create the symbol for a split second as well,
seemingly reminding him of his mission to
destroy Voldemort's horcruxes.
Fans could launch a full-scale Easter egg
hunt to find all the other nods to this paramount
piece of symbolism because it's been scattered
throughout the film series in small moments
such as these.
Trelawney's prophecies
Hermione Granger didn't care much for Divination,
but Professor Trelawney's prophecies did turn
out to be astonishingly accurate, even when
she seemed her kookiest.
The one that most people point to as prescient
in retrospect is from the books.
At one point, she declined a dinner invitation
in Prisoner of Azkaban because twelve people
were already seated and thirteen is unlucky.
The theory then was that the first person
to rise from a table of 13 would be the first
to die, and, as fate would have it, Sirius
Black stood first from a table of such number
in Harry Potter and the Order of the Phoenix.
And yes, he died first.
But it takes an especially keen sensibility
to ferret out that her birthday claim about
Harry was also ultimately on point, even though
it seemed way off at the time.
In the same chapter in Prisoner of Azkaban,
she said she thought he was born in midwinter,
but he answered that his birthday was actually
in July.
However, Voldemort's birthday was New Year's
Eve, and since Harry had a piece of Voldemort
lodged in his soul after surviving the attack
on his family, well, she was kinda right then,
wasn't she?
Plus, of course, she totally called it when
she said...
The chocolate frog bookend
There's a small wink to Harry's first journey
on the Hogwarts Express contained in the very
last scene of Deathly Hallows: Part 2.
During Harry's first ride, when he initially
befriended Ron Weasley, he'd used his new
pocket full of Gringotts galleons to buy "the
lot" of treats on the trolley.
It didn't take long for he and Ron to stuff
their faces with all the bewitched goodies
they could stomach.
One of the chocolate frogs, however, got away
and hopped through the window, which wasn't
so much of a problem for Ron since he was
more interested in collecting the character
cards that came with them anyway.
In the final film, as Harry and Ginny's children
board the same train with Ron and Hermione's
kids, the chocolate frog returns to the window
as a nod to the start of a new story — this
time, with boy wizard Albus Severus Potter
unknowingly beginning his journey as the Cursed
Child.
Voldemort was in Hogwarts the whole time
In the film version of Prisoner of Azkaban,
there's a moment when the students are walking
through the staircase when an unexpectedly
familiar face pops up in a portrait: Lord
Voldemort.
It's a blurred and fairly quick pass-by situation,
but that's gotta be him–a Nosferatu-like
bald wizard in flowing black capes reaching
out to the students that pass him by in his
menacing way.
If it seems odd that Voldemort's portrait
would be included in the halls of Hogwarts,
that's because it is odd.
Not only was he dubbed "He-Who-Shall-Not-Be-Named"
by everyone and kept far, far away from the
mainstream wizarding community, but Ralph
Fiennes hadn't yet arrived as the character.
It'd be a whole 'nother installment — The
Goblet of Fire — before he'd show up.
Foreshadowing much?
Dial 6-2-4-4-2 for magic
In Order of the Phoenix, Harry is called to
the Ministry of Magic to have a disciplinary
hearing before the Wizengamot after producing
his Patronus to save himself and cousin Dudley
from a Dementor while in the Muggle realm.
Mr. Weasley accompanies Harry to the hearing
and takes Harry into a telephone box to get
access to the Ministry.
In the book, he narrates the number he's dialing
to get through as 6-2-4-4-2.
On a traditional telephone like that one,
the letters would be arranged on the keypad
as well and those digits just so happen to
spell "M-A-G-I-C."
There's no chance that was a coincidence.
Hedwig's theme
The score to the Harry Potter film series
has become quite an earworm since the films
were released, unmistakably belonging to the
series forevermore.
The introductory music has been titled "Hedwig's
Theme," but the character who actually played
the music during the movie was Hagrid.
In the first film, he plays the melody on
his flute as Harry, Ron, and Hermione all
rush up to him for critical information on
their latest meanderings around the school
grounds.
Maybe it should've been called "Hagrid's Theme"
instead?
Aberforth's bar
There's a scene in The Order of the Phoenix
when Harry, Ron, and Hermione duck out of
Hogwarts to formulate Dumbledore's Army at
Hogsmeade.
When they hit up the Hog's Head, a local bar,
for some private planning, they find that
there's just one other person there: a bartender
lurking in the dark.
And he's got a goat.
Only J.K.
Rowling's most faithful DA members would have
recognized that this was an early glimpse
of Albus Dumbledore's brother, Aberforth...who
was obsessed with goats.
And owned a bar.
That establishment would later come into play
again in Deathly Hallows: Part 2 when the
trio tries to sneak back into Hogwarts during
another troublesome Headmaster switcheroo
moment–this time, with Aberforth arriving
to lend a hand.
Opening at the close
There's a lot that can be read into the Snitch's
inscription that so famously read "I open
at the close."
The most obvious interpretation is that, when
Harry kisses it in Deathly Hallows, it opens
itself up to present him with the Resurrection
Stone so he can have a pep talk with his long-lost
loved ones before sacrificing himself to Voldemort
to fulfill his part of the prophecy.
He got it in the first book, when he started
this journey, and it opened at the close.
Simple enough, right?
What should really get the eyebrows raising,
though, is the fact that Rowling published
the first book back in 1997, when the events
of Deathly Hallows took place.
So, it's also a statement that symbolizes
the entire franchise as a whole.
It literally opens at the close.
Is this all in Harry's head?
One of the grimmest fan theories associated
with the Harry Potter books and films is the
idea that everything magical about Harry's
life outside of 4 Privet Drive was just a
cruel fiction of his overactive imagination.
The idea behind this one is that Harry, who
was a tortured orphan and was made to live
in the closet under the stairs by his cruel
aunt and uncle, created this fictional reality
as a coping mechanism for his circumstances.
And in the final installment, there's a momentary
wink to that very possibility — and a possible
acknowledgment that it may be right on the
money after all.
After Harry has died by Voldemort's wand and
wakes up in a dreamy version of King's Cross
Station, he meets with Dumbledore, who gives
him the option to stay in the living realm
or go onto the beyond.
Harry asks Dumbledore if this is in his head
and Dumbledore answers like so:
"Is this all real, or is it just happening
inside my head?"
"Of course it’s happening inside your head,
Harry.
Why should that mean that it's not real?"
To fans looking for confirmation of that theory,
there's really only one possible response:
"And bloody hell!"
Thanks for watching!
Click the Looper icon to subscribe to our
YouTube channel.
Plus check out all this cool stuff we know
you'll love, too!